the area kyle canyon and the 95 may not
look like much now it's a little windier
but i do like the views but soon
hundreds of people will be calling this
area home i moved back here recently
after living here 20 years ago gina
sampson just bought a home in this new
area called sunstone all the urban
sprawl i know it will come eventually
she closes on her home in the spring
sunstone is has been extremely well
received while it may seem far to some
coldwell banker chairman and ceo bob
hamrick says the age-restricted
neighborhood for 55 and older in
sunstone is proving to be popular
they've had tremendous success selling
about 30 units every single month one a
day he says it has been predicted that
the north valley and north las vegas
will be the number one selling areas of
the valley for years to come there's a
lot of land there's a lot more
development to take place and ultimately
they're selling it for less so people
are making the decision to move there
versus the other some of the other
communities you won't find any
restaurants or shops out here at
sunstone right now but hamrick says
usually the homes are built first and
then the commercial development comes
after that sampson knows more will come
but the amenities that will be here like
the clubhouse and even the proximity to
mount charleston are appealing hopefully
i can stay pretty active joe mohler live
local now